Ein Hof am See:
Sylvia und Markus Buob
suchen die Ruhe in Schweden.
Sie wollen dort
Ferienwohnungen vermieten.
Viva Mexico:
Stefano Lotti und Stefano Navarretta
zieht es in die Karibik.
Im Land des Tequila
wittern sie ihre Chance.
Und Familie Tokay möchte sich
in Südafrika neu erfinden.
Ihr Traum: eine eigene Lodge.
(Doris) Das ist ja
ein echt cooler Laster.
Der Hausrat aus dem Thurgau.
Familie Tokay ist vor fünf Wochen
nach Südafrika aufgebrochen.
Good morning, good morning.
Die letzten Meter
für den riesigen Hochseecontainer.
Er ist voller Umzugskisten.
Der schafft das
doch nicht um die Ecke.
* Sie atmet erschrocken ein. *
Der schafft es locker.
Schau dir das an!
75 m3 - das gesamte Hab und Gut
der Familie.
Ich freue mich,
dass das Zeug da ist.
Die Plombe ist jedenfalls noch dran.
A 032 ...
... 4807.
- Stimmt's noch?
Yeah. Es stimmt.
- Es ist noch dieselbe.
Es ist wie ein Stück Heimat,
das eingetroffen ist.
Zwar nicht das Haus,
aber alles, was drin war.
Schön.
In der letzten Folge
kam Familie Tokay nicht mehr voran.
Wir gehen nicht zurück, nur
weil nicht alles nach Plan läuft.
Ihr Traum von der Gästefarm
ist geplatzt.
Ohne eine gute Idee
können sie hier nicht bleiben.
Das Konzept ist nach wie vor,
etwas im Gästebereich zu machen.
Stefano Navarretta übernahm in Mexiko
erstmalig Geschäfte seines Onkels.
Mi primer contracto.
Home, sweet home.
Die Auswanderer bezogen ihre eigenen
Wohnungen - alles war eingerichtet.
Mein Onkel
behandelt mich wie einen Sohn.
* Abschiedsworte *
In Schweden sind Markus und Sylvia
Buob nun auf sich alleine gestellt.
Ihr erstes Projekt: Zwei Ferien-
wohnungen auf ihrem Hof herrichten.
Der Raum ist zu klein für den
Kontrast, den du dir vorstellst.
# Uf u dervo.
In Südafrika ist es endlich so weit.
Die Sicherheitsplombe ist weg.
Nach 9'000 km.
Ist es noch gleich, Tibi?
Ja, ist alles gut. Alles gut.
Uah! Help!
* Tibor lacht laut. *
Das wird ja abenteuerlich.
Das meiste hat Familie Tokay
aus ihrem Haus am Bodensee
ins neue Leben mitgenommen.
Schade, dass wir es
noch zwischenlagern müssen.
Alles auspacken und sich einrichten
geht aber noch nicht.
Die Villa in Stanford
hat Familie Tokay
vorerst für zwei Monate gemietet.
Es ist schon wichtig,
dass man ein Auge darauf hat.
Denn es kann gut sein,
dass etwas abgezweigt wird.
Dass die eine oder andere Schachtel
nicht im Haus,
sondern woanders landet.
Darum ist es wichtig.
Ich schaue kurz, was das ist.
17'000 Fr. liessen sie sich
den Umzug bis jetzt schon kosten.
Unsere Kellerräumlichkeiten
in Steckborn waren ja sehr gross.
Jetzt sieht man, was da
anscheinend alles im Keller war.
Ach, ein Davoser Schlitten.
* Doris lacht. *
Den haben wir einfach aus
Nostalgiegründen mitgenommen.
Obwohl wir ihn hier
nie brauchen werden.
Aber er ist trotzdem dabei:
ein Davoser Schlitten.
Das ist unser grösster Schatz:
unsere Fahrräder,
unsere Mountainbikes.
Zwölf. Genau.
Ja, das braucht man halt.
* Fröhliche Trommelklänge *
Nach 2 1/2 Std.
sind die Schätze wieder verstaut
und bis auf Weiteres eingelagert.
Oh! Aber mehr als nur knapp.
Meine Güte!
Von ihren ursprünglichen Plänen
für das neue Leben
ist Familie Tokay noch weit entfernt.
Playa del Carmen - expandierender
Ferienort in der Karibik.
Stefano Navarretta
und Mitarbeiterin Leslie
besuchen Kunden von Stefanos Onkel.
(Leslie) Hola! Ciao!
- (Stefano) Buongiorno, buenos dias!
Leslie zeigt ihm,
wie das Geschäft läuft.
Son dos o tres contenarios al ano.
- Al ano?
Porque esto es especialidad.
Weil dies
ein Spezialitätengeschäft ist,
importieren wir nur zwei bis drei
Container jährlich für sie.
Nicht wie bei den Hotelketten,
für die jeden Monat
mehrere Container kommen.
Es ist wirklich ein Spezialitäten-
geschäft, das wir hier beliefern.
Eine neue Bestellung.
Die Delikatessen Öl, Pasta, Wein
kommen direkt aus Italien.
Stefano will das Geschäft
weiter ausbauen.
Muchas gracias. Nos vemos.
- Gracias a ti.
Van a ir a la oficina?
- Vamos a la oficina. Vengo contigo.
Ein Leben als Accountmanager.
In dieses Geschäft des Onkels
muss sich Stefano erst einleben.
Der 31-Jährige hatte im Baselbiet
zusammen mit seinem Geschäftspartner
eine Personalagentur
und vermittelte Handwerker
auf Baustellen.
Die Pasta aus Italien
muss mit Know-how, Beziehungen
und Einfühlungsvermögen
durch den Zoll gebracht werden.
Es ist auf jeden Fall neu.
Ich habe mich
noch nie damit befasst.
Sie macht es sehr gut, erklärt es
mir langsam. Ich verstehe alles.
Ein neues Geschäftsfeld. Stefano
erobert es Schritt für Schritt.
Okay.
In der Casa Italia hat der andere
Stefano den Kopf ganz woanders.
Die beiden besitzen in der Schweiz
immer noch ein Zweifamilienhaus,
für das sie bisher
keinen Käufer gefunden haben.
Nun haben sich endlich
zwei Interessenten gemeldet.
Wir liessen den Notar
einmal einen Kaufvertrag aufsetzen.
Nun soll er noch
bis zum 31.1. warten,
weil wir noch auf Bescheid
von jemandem warten.
Gut möglich,
dass er bald zurück muss,
um den Hausverkauf abzuschliessen.
* Helle Glocke *
* Tiefes Ausatmen *
(Flüsternd) So schwer!
* Helle Glocke *
Hola, buenos dias. Tomate de Italia.
So, 10 kg. Das sollte reichen, oder?
Endlich Feierabend.
Der neue Job strengt an.
Kunden besuchen,
Formulare für den Zoll ausfüllen,
mit Leslie
Lagerbestände kontrollieren -
und das alles auf Spanisch.
* Rumpeln *
Scheisse.
Ah, sorry.
Ich habe einfach alles reingetan.
Ja.
Das ist die Müdigkeit
vom Arbeitstag.
Es waren so viele Informationen,
alles neu.
Mein Kopf raucht.
Der Notar hat geschrieben, Haas.
* Hämmern im Hintergrund *
Weshalb?
- Wegen des Kaufvertrags fürs Haus.
Nur, damit du Bescheid weisst.
* Verkehrsgeräusche *
* Instrumentalversion
der Titelmelodie *
10 ha Umschwung gehören zum Hof
der Familie Buob am See.
So viel wie 14 Fussballfelder.
* Krähen *
Markus ist gelernter Schreiner.
Zusammen mit seiner Frau
verdiente er nicht schlecht.
Sie verkaufte zuletzt als Beraterin
Holzhäuser.
Aber so ein grosses Anwesen
hätten sie sich in der alten Heimat
nie leisten können.
Es gibt in der Schweiz wenige Grund-
stücke, die mit Auto befahrbar sind.
Und wenn, dann hätten wir
wohl keinen günstigen VW-Bus,
sondern einen grossen Benz dafür -
oder einen Traktor.
Die zwei Zimmer in diesem Häuschen
wollen Buobs
an Feriengäste vermieten.
Sie werben bereits dafür
in einer Schweizer Lokalzeitung
und im Internet.
Also.
Gibst du mir Arbeitsanweisungen?
- Ja.
Hier kommen die Sachen rein, die wir
vielleicht noch brauchen können.
Und das zum Entsorgen?
- Das kommt da drüben hin.
Also.
Wegen der Schwangerschaft
übernimmt Sylvia leichtere Arbeiten.
Sie gestaltet die Wohnungen
und sucht die Möbel aus.
Wir wissen jetzt,
wie es vorher ausgesehen hat.
Und jetzt freuen wir uns auf
das Endresultat, wenn's fertig ist.
Ich schenke dir das.
- Och! Zweibeinige wären mir lieber.
* Markus ächzt. *
Hast du dir den Kopf gestossen?
Nein, den Fuss.
- Welch Überraschung.
Das passierte dieses Jahr
ja noch nicht oft.
Ach, Mann.
Z.T. weiss man
bei dem Zeug halt nicht ...
Ihr Hof am See wurde 1907 gebaut
und nach und nach erweitert.
Gut.
Es ist richtig alte Schreinerarbeit.
Dementsprechend schwer ist es auch.
- Ja.
Die beiden wollen den
ursprünglichen Charakter bewahren.
Jetzt weiss ich's wieder:
dieser blöde Fuss.
Das ist eine Freude.
* Ächzen *
Super.
Ich würde gerne mit anpacken.
Sylvia ist im siebten Monat.
Schwere Lasten sind für sie tabu.
Toll.
Jetzt ist sicher 10 Uhr.
- Jetzt willst du Kaffee.
Ja, ich mache einen.
* Verspielte Instrumentalversion
der Titelmelodie *
Ist dein Schulrucksack bereit?
Ist alles drin, was du brauchst?
* Murmeln *
Annikki hat schlecht geschlafen.
Heute beginnt für sie
und ihren Bruder die Schule.
Ich bin ziemlich aufgeregt.
Aber nicht ängstlich,
sondern eher ... freudig.
Also, hm. Ja.
Miika ist da anders.
Miika ist eher der Typ, der sagt:
"Ich habe keine Lust auf Schule,
ich will nicht,
die Hausaufgaben sind blöd."
Komm, wir gehen!
- Genau.
Also, let's fetz.
Komm, Miika, wir gehen hier raus!
Lichter löschen!
So.
* Kurzer Alarm *
* Gemütliche Trommelmelodie *
20 Min. braucht Familie Tokay
bis zur Schule.
Sie liegt in Hermanus,
einem Touristenort,
bekannt für das Whalewatching.
Die Generation School
ist eine Privatschule
mit international
anerkanntem Abschluss.
Für ihre Kinder bezahlen die Tokays
rund 500 Fr. pro Monat.
Ach, Mamas Hand hältst du,
nicht meine.
Nur wenige südafrikanische Familien
können sich das leisten.
Hi, nice to meet you.
Ist gut?
- Ja.
(Lehrerin) You are staying with him
for a little bit and then ...
No, sorry.
Du musst ihr sagen,
dass er kein Englisch spricht.
Sie wusste es nicht.
- Ah, okay.
Miikas erste Schulstunde.
Lauter neue Kameraden.
Setz dich einfach!
Schreiben, rechnen, Englisch lernen.
* Die Kinder antworten im Chor. *
Bei Miika finde ich es schon
etwas hart. Er ist völlig ... uff!
Auf der anderen Seite
habe ich das Gefühl:
Wenn sie "pencil" sagt,
wiederholt er es.
Es kommt.
Das ist jetzt einfach hart, aber
ich bin überzeugt, er schafft das.
Es ist halt ... Klar, es wäre selt-
sam, wenn man nicht mitleiden würde.
Der siebenjährige Miika
schlägt sich tapfer.
Du musst eine Geschichte schreiben.
In der Schulstube nebenan
kämpft seine Schwester Annikki.
Ah, da ist sie.
I hope we didn't disturb ...
- No, it's fine.
Als Neue in der Klasse
soll sie ein paar Aufgaben lösen.
Die Lehrerin will herausfinden,
was sie schon kann.
Anni, du musst dich nicht stressen.
Sie sagte,
die Klasse würde bald halbiert.
Es seien nur im Moment so viele.
Du musst mit den Aufgaben
nicht stressen.
Sie wollen nur schauen,
wo du stehst.
Du brauchst dir
keine Sorgen zu machen.
Mann, Mami!
Das klappt schon. Lass dir Zeit!
Es ist halt einfach zu viel.
Das geht alles Schritt für Schritt.
Step by step, okay?
Doris bleibt in der Nähe.
Erster Schultag in Südafrika.
Ein Test auch für sie.
Stefano Navarretta ist inzwischen
schon sechs Wochen allein in Mexiko
und regelt die Immobiliengeschäfte.
David, te molesta.
Stefano hat die Baustelle
fast jeden Tag kontrolliert,
seit sein Kollege in der Schweiz ist.
Er hat Klimaanlagen besorgt,
Matratzen organisiert,
die Bäder eingerichtet.
Das ist gut.
Andrea sagte mir,
das eine oder andere Klo ...
* Zögerliches Plätschern *
... verliere Wasser.
Das hier anscheinend nicht.
Hier kommt noch
ein kleiner Spiegel hin.
Der Boiler ist bereits montiert.
Die Dusche anscheinend auch.
Jawohl, okay. Das Zimmer ist bereit.
Ich möchte es heute fotografieren.
Die Vorhänge
muss ich noch montieren.
Sie sind schon gekauft.
Dann wären wir eigentlich ready.
Stefano hat den Bau zügig vorange-
trieben mit seinem Bauleiter Andrea.
Ohne Hilfe von Onkel Fernando.
Er sagte,
ich müsse das selber machen,
er spiele nicht Papi,
ich sei alt genug.
Damit war ich auch einverstanden.
Ich bin nur froh um seine Hilfe,
bzw. davon abhängig
für
die ganze Bewilligungsgeschichte.
Ausserdem haben wir
unterschiedliche Geschmäcker.
Ich komme aus der Schweiz,
ich mag Qualität.
Er ist eher Amerikaner -
alles in Quantität, günstig.
Da muss man einen Mittelweg finden.
Die Apartments sind die erste
Investition der Auswanderer
in eine Immobilie in Mexiko.
Liestal im Baselbiet.
Stefano Lotti
ist nun schon seit sechs Wochen hier
und sucht einen Käufer für ihr Haus.
Ja, das Herz ist schon in Mexiko.
Aber der Kopf ist natürlich hier.
Aber ich bin froh,
dass Stefano vor Ort ist.
Wir konnten uns
auch nur so aufteilen.
Mit meinem Spanisch hätte ich dort
nicht viel hingekriegt.
In ihrer alten Firma war Stefano für
Buchhaltung und Technik zuständig.
Die Rolle als Verkäufer
ist neu für ihn.
Bisher machte das der andere Stefano.
* Langer Seufzer *
Das Zweifamilienhaus
war Teil ihrer alten Firma.
Hier haben sie
etliche Leiharbeiter untergebracht.
Seit einem halben Jahr steht es leer.
Wir haben eine Absage
von einem Interessenten erhalten,
von dem wir dachten ...
* WC-Spülung *
... mit dem würde es klappen.
Aber jetzt wagen wir
einen neuen Versuch.
Ein Makler
soll Schwung in den Verkauf bringen.
Und Stefano klappert
noch einmal den Bekanntenkreis ab.
Wir könnten es theoretisch
auch selber umbauen und vermieten,
wenn wir niemanden finden.
Es ist zwar vielleicht blöd
zu verwalten
und man muss
vielleicht etwas abgeben,
aber so gebundenes Kapital
ist grundsätzlich
keine Falschinvestition.
Hier dauert einfach
alles viel länger
als an einem boomenden Touristenort
wie Playa del Carmen.
Stefano ist sicher: In Mexiko könnten
sie mit dem Geld aus dem Hausverkauf
noch viel mehr Profit machen.
Die Sauna ist wohl auch nicht nötig.
In Schweden steht die erste
Schwangerschaftsuntersuchung an.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wenn die kein Englisch sprechen,
haben wir ein Problem.
Ich schaue kurz,
was "gebären" usw. heisst.
Der Geburtstermin rückt näher.
In der Frauenklinik in Vimmerby
will Sylvia einen Termin
mit der Hebamme vereinbaren.
* Schwedische
Telefonbeantworter-Ansage *
Aha, Moment.
* Tastentöne *
Sylvia und Markus haben
einen Schwedisch-Grundkurs besucht
und ein paar Privatlektionen
genommen.
* Signalton *
Es geht nicht.
Sie sagt, man solle
die vollständige Nummer eingeben.
Aber ich habe nur diese Nummer hier
im Internet.
Telefonzeit - doch, das stimmt auch.
* Schwedische
Telefonbeantworter-Ansage *
Hm.
* Freizeichen *
Ende des ersten Schultags.
Miika zeigt, was er gelernt hat.
I'm such a good teacher.
Doris ist erleichtert,
Miika so fröhlich anzutreffen.
Nicht wahr?
Du bist ein cleverer Bursche.
Ich friere.
- More or less an hour? Okay.
Hey, pst!
- Ich friere.
Gut hast du es gemacht.
Das ist doch super!
Bald sprichst du besser als ich.
Ist Annikki noch drin?
- Ja, die hat noch eine Lektion.
Noch 30 Min.
(Lehrerin) 3 October,
just write it somewhere.
Annikki versucht mitzuhalten.
In der Primarschule
in Steckborn am Bodensee
hatte sie zwei Jahre Frühenglisch.
Ich glaube,
es ist noch ein Auf und Ab.
Aber ich finde, am ersten Tag kann
man sagen: "Ihr habt's geschafft."
"Wieso soll der nächste Tag
nicht zu schaffen sein?"
Jetzt wird es ja leichter.
Wir müssen noch auf Papa warten.
- Was hat Miika so gemacht?
Das muss er selber erzählen.
- Ich hatte Englisch, Mathe ...
Oh, Englisch!
- ... und Musik.
Ach, auch Musik?
Das habe ich verpasst. Cool.
Sylvia hat beschlossen, direkt
bei der Hebamme vorbeizufahren.
Ehemann Markus
kommt selbstverständlich mit.
Das ist's doch, oder?
- Ich würde auch sagen.
Also, schauen wir mal.
* Sie lesen
die schwedischen Tafeln. *
Ich glaube,
du musst noch eins weiter.
* Sie lesen
die schwedischen Tafeln. *
War es wohl das?
Oder ist es das hier?
Nehmen wir den!
- "Reserviert für ..."
Ich würde gerne,
aber der ganze Platz ist reserviert.
Irgendwo muss die Frauenklinik sein.
Fahr doch da mal rein!
Das ist MFVC ...
- MVC.
Mödravardscentral - kann das sein?
Ich gehe mal fragen.
Fragen wir einfach mal.
Was will man sonst tun?
Die Auswanderer haben Glück.
Die Hebamme spricht Englisch
und nimmt sich spontan Zeit
für eine erste Sprechstunde.
Mehr oder weniger das Gegenteil
dessen, was wir erwartet haben.
Wir dachten, wir müssten warten.
Aber sie sind freundlich.
Sie ist sich ausländische Patienten
gewohnt. Es ist gut.
Du far lägga dig pa britsen.
Dann schaut die Hebamme,
wie es dem Baby geht.
Bisher verlief die Schwangerschaft
ohne Probleme.
Dennoch sind Buobs vorsichtig.
Sylvia hatte
bereits drei Fehlgeburten.
* Rauschende Ultraschallgeräusche *
Man hört die Herztöne.
Aber ... Da ist noch etwas anderes.
Do you know ...
Ah!
* Markus lacht. *
Now?
- Yes, now.
Nicht dass sie denkt,
es trinke zu viel!
Nein, nein.
Danke.
Also alles in Ordnung.
Bis zur Geburt wird die Hebamme
Sylvia regelmässig untersuchen.
Was heisst, nächstes Mal?
Till mandag.
Ja.
- Vi ses.
Sie scheint gut, oder?
- Ja, ich bin sehr happy.
Das ist super:
Wir sind hier gemeldet
und wir wissen, wohin,
wenn etwas wäre. Ein gutes Gefühl.
* Sanfte Melodie *
Sonne, Meer, Karibik.
Es ist wirklich ein Traum.
Ein Traum, den ich lebe.
Ich hoffe,
auch Stefano kann ihn bald leben.
Er fehlt - als Geschäftspartner
und auch als Freund.
Denn wir haben das hier
ja zusammen geplant.
Aber seine Zeit wird auch kommen.
Es ist nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Stefano Navarretta
hat mittlerweile sein erstes Geld
mit den Apartments in der Casa Italia
gemacht.
Er hat sie tageweise vermietet.
Sein Apartment, das seines Kollegen
und die Wochenendwohnung
seines Onkels auch noch gleich mit.
Vielleicht sind sie noch nicht da.
Ciao ragazzi. Permesso?
- (Mann) Prego.
Come va? Tutto bene?
- Bene, bene.
Posso entrare?
- Si, si.
Come va? Tutto bene?
Onkel Fernandos Apartment haben vier
Italiener für zwei Nächte bevölkert.
Jetzt überprüfe ich hier gerade,
ob alles gut ist,
ob nichts kaputt ist.
Denn sonst
muss ich es ihnen verrechnen.
Hier ist alles gut, in Ordnung.
Gut.
Okay, alles in Ordnung.
Grazie, grazie.
Nur noch putzen,
dann ist die Wohnung wieder bereit
für die nächsten zahlenden Gäste.
Fate buon viaggio!
Stefano muss gleich weiter
nach Cancun.
Er hat einen Termin bei seinem Onkel.
* Er singt und pfeift
ein kolumbianisches Lied. *
Onkel Fernando wartet schon.
Fernandos Firmen und Liebschaften
laufen rund.
Und der Neffe hat die Geschäfte schon
nach wenigen Wochen fest im Griff.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Ganz einfach und schnell.
Es ging besser,
als ich gedacht hatte.
Er versteht die Leute schnell
und weiss sie zu führen.
Ich habe ihn sogar
aus seiner Wohnung geworfen,
weil ich sie vermieten konnte.
Zuerst wurde er sauer,
aber dann fand er:
"Okay, ist gut.
Du bist sehr schnell."
Er wollte gerade
in seiner Wohnung schlafen gehen.
Jetzt habe ich am Strand
keine Wohnung mehr.
Er dachte nicht,
dass es so schnell gehen würde.
Aber das ist schon gut.
Kein Problem.
Besser, er übt. Besser so,
als wenn er schlafen würde.
Er macht keine Siesta.
Er ist ein Schweizer Arbeiter.
Gehen wir zum Anwalt runter.
Die Anwältin hat ihr Büro
nur ein Stockwerk tiefer.
Io mi sono portato il passaporto,
va bene?
Hola, como estas?
- Hola, buenos dias.
Auch sie gehört zu Fernandos Plan.
Mucho gusto. Stefano.
Das ist mein Anwalt.
Ein sehr schöner Anwalt.
Gracias.
- Vamos!
Die Anwältin hat Neuigkeiten:
Stefanos Aufenthaltsbewilligung
wurde genehmigt
und wird in Kürze ausgestellt.
Stefano hat ein erstes Ziel erreicht.
Ab sofort darf er in Mexiko
arbeiten - auch ohne seinen Onkel.
Diese Aussicht kann man kaufen.
Meine Güte!
Das könnte Tokays Alltag werden.
Man sieht eigentlich
die ganze Bucht.
Ja, und unverbaubar. Hammer!
Dieses Haus steigert sich im Wert.
Denn man kann nichts verlieren.
Nein. Sehr schön.
- Hammer.
Aus dem Doppelhaus liessen sich
leicht vier Ferienwohnungen machen.
Solides Buchenholz!
Das glaubt man ja gar nicht.
Wahnsinn.
Also die Küche ist super.
Das ist eine Art Apartment,
wie wir sie z.T. gemietet haben.
Man kommt rein und findet es genial.
Mit dieser Sicht!
Da will man gar nicht mehr weg.
Genau so etwas will man.
Und das mit den Halbebenen
finde ich sowieso mega cool.
Schönes Cheminee.
Ferienapartments
kaufen und vermieten -
eine neue Idee von Doris und Tibor.
Es ist der absolute Hammer.
Sind heute keine Wale zu sehen?
- Nein.
Gibt's denn das?
Man könnte vielleicht
schon einen sehen.
Da ist doch einer.
- Ja, dort. Wahnsinn.
Weiter vorne ist noch einer,
glaube ich.
Jetzt sieht man ihn gut. Schau!
- Ja.
Voll raus.
- Mega schön.
* Doris lacht. *
"Kommt her!"
Komm, wir winken zurück! Huhu!
Wahnsinn! Schön.
Der macht ein Riesenschauspiel.
Schon genial.
- Ja.
Mega schön.
Jeder Tourist wird sagen:
"Genau das will ich."
"Ich will Meersicht,
will Wale und Haie sehen."
Sie wollen die schönen Wege begehen.
All das findet man in so einem Haus.
Tokays nähern sich ihrem Traum
Schritt für Schritt.
Ein Haus mit Walsicht -
Whalewatching.
Die Begeisterung hält an.
Schon bald werden sie
den Vorvertrag unterschreiben.
* Sanfter Flötenklang *
In Schweden haben bereits erste Som-
mergäste die Ferienwohnungen gebucht.
* Hämmern *
Acht Wochen hat Markus eingeplant.
Dann sollen zwei Ferienhäuser
saniert sein.
Danach will er sich
einen Job auf dem Bau suchen.
Um allein vom Sommertourismus
zu leben,
bräuchten wir schon mehr
als zwei Ferienhäuser.
Ich habe mir gesagt: In zehn Jahren
möchte ich vom Hof leben.
Aber so lange werde ich hier
als Schreiner arbeiten.
Ist auch nicht das Schlimmste
in einem Land,
in dem alles
so schön auf Holzbasis ist.
Hier bringt man Handwerkern noch
eine gewisse Wertschätzung entgegen.
* Knarren *
Noch ist der Boden,
auf dem sie sich bewegen, unsicher.
Und das schon seit einem Jahr.
Ihr Hof am See, Snokebo Gard,
muss neu vermessen werden.
Bis dahin stehen sie nicht
als Eigentümer im Grundbuch.
Mittlerweile zweifeln sie daran,
dass das in absehbarer Zeit passiert.
Wir haben Post.
- Ich?
Wir.
- Ah, vom Skatteverket?
Vom Lantmäteriet.
- Alter Schwede!
Am Onsdag, 12. April,
beginnen Sie um 11 Uhr zu vermessen.
Nein!
- Ja, ue!
Es geht los.
- Am 12. April.
That's it.
Das heisst,
dass in genau einer Woche
endlich das Land
fertig vermessen wird.
Das wird in einem Tag gemacht sein.
Am nächsten Tag
wird's in das System genommen
und am übernächsten
ins Grundbuch eingetragen.
Und dann ist alles fertig.
- Echt, geht das so schnell?
Ja, zack, zack, zack, hiess es.
* Brutzeln *
Wie lange dauert's noch?
Es dauert ... ähm, 10-15 Min.
Dann gehe ich noch mal runter
und mache weiter.
Zwölf Pack Keramikfliesen.
Stefano hat im Baumarkt
ein Schnäppchen gemacht.
So kann er den Bau der Apartments
zügig abschliessen.
Ich will es eben
bis morgen fertig haben.
Wir müssen nur zwei Bäder machen,
darum haben wir es
gleich hier gekauft.
Wegen der Ausrede:
"Wir haben kein Material."
Ich dachte,
die sehen ziemlich gut aus.
Darum haben wir die letzten 60 m
einfach noch hier gekauft.
Zeit ist für Stefano bares Geld.
Muchas gracias.
- Gracias.
(Beide) Hasta luego.
Und Playa del Carmen ist der ideale
Ort für schnelle Entscheidungen.
Stefanos italienischer Bauleiter
ist auf der gleichen Wellenlänge.
Die neue Heimat der Auswanderer
war bis vor 50 Jahren
ein kleines Fischerdorf.
Heute leben hier
über 250'000 Menschen.
Der Tourismus boomt.
Hier befinden wir uns beim nächsten
Projekt. Es soll Amalfi heissen.
Das ist das Land, das wir haben.
Bzw. Fernando hat es.
Ein Haus mit mindestens acht
Apartments soll hier entstehen.
Finanziert durch wohlhabende Käufer,
die bei den Stefanos
eine Ferienwohnung erwerben.
So ihr Plan.
Das Business hier ist:
kaufen, bauen, verkaufen.
Damit man in zehn Jahren
sein Stück vom Kuchen
wird abgeschnitten haben können.
Hier ergibt sich eine Möglichkeit.
Und wir sind hier,
um diese Möglichkeit zu ergreifen.
Und hier dasselbe: Wir fragen,
ob wir das auch kaufen können.
Aber nichts ist sicher.
Mit dem nötigen Kleingeld lässt
sich das Rad immer schneller drehen.
Man muss schon darauf achten,
auf dem Boden zu bleiben.
Aber no risk no fun.
Ich lebe schliesslich nur einmal.
Und ich war immer risikofreudig,
sonst wäre ich mit 31
nicht so weit gekommen.
Von daher ...
Nächste Woche bei "Auf und davon":
Wiedersehen in der Schweiz.
Mama!
Stefano Navarretta stellt
seine neue Freundin vor: Leslie.
Und Stefano Lotti
hat endlich Interessenten gefunden.
Wie immer sehr schick gekleidet.
Das Kleine da unten
ist jetzt dein Reich.
Sylvia Buob
begrüsst in Snokebo den ersten Gast.
Wirklich süss.
Ach, ich werde wahnsinnig.
Ihr Mann Markus, der Schreiner,
kämpft mit schwedischen Möbeln.
In Südafrika zweifeln Tokays.
Doch kein Traumhaus?
Dann denkt man: "Verflucht,
was genau machen wir hier?"
Are you also coming
tomorrow evening?
Yes, yes, we'll come.
Und sie helfen mit
beim Herbstfest in der neuen Heimat.